So, I know I want to rename all of my files. And I remember there were about
50 photos, inside that folder that you downloaded. So,
to rename 50 photos, I think I'll have to
use some sort of a loop. So, I'll
just write one down now by saying, for file_name,
in file_list. Now, bear in mind, file_list is something
we've seen before. In fact, we printed it out.
This was a list of all of the photos inside
the folder. And what this for loop is going to
allow us to do is work with each photo file
one at a time. So, for each photo, I want to change
its name. And the old name is in file_name. And
the new name, well, I know the new name is devoid
of any numbers. But how to do that, I still
don't know. And this means I'll have to do some experimentation.
And to run those experiments I generally use the
Python Shell window, where I can just start typing
and seeing the result really quickly. Let me make
more room for this window so you can see
it properly. So, say, my file name was the
following string; 48athens.jpg. Let me print that out, okay,
good. Now, previously I Googled to find out that
there is a string function called translate that takes
up to two arguments. The first argument is a
table. Which translates one set of characters to another set
of characters and since we don't have that, I can
use the keyword none. And the second is a list
of all characters that we want to remove from
the string. And those I know are numbers, so that
will be zero, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine. All of those numbers. Let me try that.
Oh hey, look, the file name now has
no numbers in it. So, because that experiment
worked, I will go back to the code
and add this file_ name.translate function into my code.